Hello Freak bitches.
Well,
that's nature man.
She just so creepy and it's,
it's ways of adjusting to life.
My friend and dress Antonopoulos,
uh,
my,
my friend,
the bitcoin expert explained this to me last weekend in Vegas.
Ducks have three foot long dicks that curl and twist because the female vaginas
have adapted to fight off rape.
Duck rape.
Yeah.
So they have these pussies that are the,
these fucking laboratories,
these twisty turny,
elaborative pussies and they can choose to let sperm in,
are not let sperm in with their gigantic labyrinth,
pussies and these three foot long duck dicks.
When you see a duck's deck you like,
Whoa,
that is not real.
Look at that ducks deck.
That's a drawing.
But there's actual photograph.
That's an actual photograph of a duct.
Dick.
What in the fuck?
That's like a person but like a 15 foot long dick.
Yeah.
Ducks are tiny man horse trailer deck.
Like a person with a three foot dick is a monster.
But a duck with a three foot long dick is totally standard.
That's a deck that's a Olympian.
That's guy's a little,
a little deck.
He gets shamed by the other ducks.
Poor guy.
Yeah.
I mean duct dicks are ridiculous.
They're,
it's a fucking ridiculous animal.
What docs,
I knew the ducks engaged in rape,
gang rape.
Oh,
that's all they do.
The ceiling gang up on one.
Look out.
Look how the,
the female's vagina has sort of adapted to deal with the male raping,
you know,
created these bizarre pathways in their pussies.
Yeah,
no,
a mighty mouse is,
he's a,
he's interesting.
I know you've been a big fan of him and I've always enjoyed watching that guy.
I mean I can't fight like that guy,
but to watch some of his techniques and the way you use angles and footwork and
how he lures you in and his clinch game is,
is uh,
is nasty.
Just nasty.
You know,
I wonder,
and maybe you could give some insight on this.
Like you used to fight at one 55 and now you've got to cut to get down to one 45
year.
A pretty big guy.
But mighty mouse is not a big guy.
And I always wonder like,
could a guy like good a light heavyweight or a middleweight even,
could they possibly even fight like him or is that a gravity thing?
Like is it,
is part of what's going on with him?
The fact that he's so light,
like he can move faster,
he's got like more options as far as like what he can do.
Some people were a blessed with a better integrated and their body such as like
a neutral spine.
A lot of people have like lumbar problems in neutral spine.
You ever watch Mayweather?
He,
you don't ever see them lean and he's just always in constantly good posture and
good position.
And just like in wrestling,
if you're in good position,
more than likely you're gonna win the fight.
Mighty mouse,
he just has that type of movement and integrates his whole body.
His body moves as one,
it doesn't work against them.
There's not like a lot of rattle in his body safe.
He throws a kick,
he doesn't land awkward.
He doesn't,
yeah,
it goes,
he goes right back to a neutral base and he's able to laterally move and
constantly have his body working for him.
So I think him naturally,
he just has that type of gifts and benefits of his body's able to integrate his
body to work as one.
Therefore you,
you don't waste a lot of energy has really fluid movement.
Look at,
uh,
a guy like Anderson Silva.
He's able to beat people just by keeping his range and it,
and just his movement of his body.
He doesn't,
he doesn't swing like a Mark Hunt or,
or me where,
you know,
like I'll,
I'll throw a lot of powers and normally I miss,
you know,
I'm just trying to,
trying to reach them,
but them guys,
they just use fluid movement and that's,
I think some people are just blessed to have that integrated in their body in a
good neutral spine and a good solid base.
And that's why they're able to connect on their shots a lot more.
It's as competing,
disconnected,
like,
uh,
say like a short circuit.
If it,
if there's like a small,
like little detail,
like this cord right here,
say it's like,
it's like broken and you're not getting like the full amount of energy as where
if you have a solid base and a good good spine,
you know how to integrate your body to use as one,
there's gonna be a lot more of a sturdier connection and more flow and fluid
movement.
I mean,
it was,
uh,
it was tough doing the talk.
And then,
um,
whenever I got into Congo,
they told me I had the flu in London and the doctors there and that's what I
feel like here to,
there can be tropical medical medicine specialist here and they're probably
really great.
But I,
I would trust the doctor that's lived in the climate of the tropical climate
around malaria that seen it.
That's true.
That knows all the symptoms,
well knows to look for it because no one gets it over here.
Yeah.
And so whenever I got into Congo,
I flew from,
yeah.
From work to Congo.
And whenever I landed,
instead of going straight to the forest,
they took me to like a air strip at a,
uh,
kind of hospital in the middle of nowhere.
Um,
so I landed,
went straight to the hospital and then right there they're like,
you don't have the flu,
you have malaria.
And I'm like,
but I,
I've been,
I've been in the states,
I just fought and then I have,
uh,
and then I was in Europe.
Like there's no,
no malaria really there,
but it was because it's still living inside me.
There's like,
um,
I think there's three strands.
One live in your body for three years,
five years.
I think the other is like 30 to life or something.
Why?
Yeah.
And so,
so it just comes back.
Yeah.
Can like when your body's really rundown,
when you're really tired,
immune systems low like training for a fight.
Yeah.
Like training for a fight or right after the fight,
right off the fight,
went to London and spoke,
then I went to Congo.
But right after the fight.
So you recovering from malaria,
you go through your six week fight camp,
you have your fight,
you're run down.
And then after the fight you got malaria again.
Yes.
Uh,
now those sickness.
Yeah.
I,
I've had it now three times.
Oh my God.
So at least confirm twice.
The third time they're like,
yeah,
you have it for sure.
But the,
with malaria you have to get the test,
the blood test while you have a certain degree temperature like fever,
uh,
whenever it's cycling out of your liver,
I mean coming out.
Um,
they have to draw the blood at that exact time to get it.
And so that's why I was misdiagnosed four times in the Congo.
And um,
what a sneaky fucking disease.
Yeah,
it's nuts.
It's crazy.
Cause they'll,
they'll hide in your liver and then they send them out in your bloodstream like
a,
like a platoon.
They go and wreck havoc and then they retreat right back to the liver.
Really?
Yeah.
They live in your liver?
That's where they're hiding away for three or five or 30 years.
Oh my God.
And what does,
is there any solution?
Is there anything they could do?
Um,
I don't think so.
And I had a couple things that happened where,
um,
you know,
I,
I started trying to take the anti malaria meds but I started getting,
it's the only medicine I've ever really reacted to where getting nauseous start
dragging him heard.
It's awful.
Yeah.
Even uh,
even um,
oh I'm pasty white and I get real sun sensitive.
Um,
I know another medicine called method when um,
which is uh,
I think it's developed in Switzerland or Sweden,
supposed to be an awesome new malaria medicine.
It's actually the one thing my body kind of responds to.
But um,
but it's actually really dangerous because a,
I've seen people that are there for aid work and different stuff and do they
have to,
they have to retreat if they're there with kids and stuff,
they moved there to the country they're taking off.
Cause I'm cause Kiddos or even adults have mental breaks that they can't come
back from.
Like you can have psychotic episodes for,
I think they said like if it lasts longer than a week,
it's probably in the last like three months to last longer than three months.
It's probably the last forever.
Wow.
So I'm,
so this is from the medication?
Yeah.
Just the medication and it gives you terrible,
terrible nightmares.
I almost went to Tanzania this summer.
What was going to go on safari and too many people scare the shit out of me with
malaria talk.
Yeah.
I was going to take my whole family and I'm like,
look,
I'll take some malaria,
malaria medication and feel like shit.
I'm not giving it to my six year old.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's not happening.
That would be,
I'm not doing enough when you yeah,
but that's a real concern.
Right?
Tanzania has malaria as well,
right?
Yeah,
they do.
It's it because it's more of a,
was that arid climate more?
It's,
they have less there.
It's not so tropical there.
I've been to Tanzania a couple of times and Sam's a bar.
I mean,
it's just,
um,
I,
it wasn't there,
but I was saw it and it was a,
I don't know,
I mean it's,
it's a crazy,
crazy place because you go from Congo where they have all these tropical
diseases and you go,
I don't know,
the same continent.
You just go over a little bit.
And there's all these other kinds of parasites.
Like in Congo,
they have very little of a,
I believe they're cold.
Um,
jiggers with a j and m it said chicken.
It's very careful when you say that word,
but jiggers with a j he's wrong.
It sounds like you should stop.
But they,
they,
they're these crazy parasites at burrow in your feet and especially kids and
elderly.
Um,
and especially my kids and elderly.
well,
honestly,
I think one reason with poverty,
uh,
the kids don't get shoes until they can work in by him and a,
the elderly,
if they're not able to work and provide for themselves.
And you know,
it's harder for them to,
to,
to get shoes and stuff,
but also it's just the,
where they live.
Um,
because on the sandy,
or it's either sandy or the clay ish,
um,
we're silty soil that's real red and Uganda,
man,
it just wreaks havoc on this kids to where they're having to have people come in
every week to different villages,
sit there with a safety pins and all sorts of these looks that they dig into the
people's feeds and,
um,
Oh God,
dude,
it's,
it's painful.
Whenever I've seen people getting it done,
you're literally putting there,
and I've had one in my foot and it kind of came and gone.
It's not that bad one,
it's just one.
But whenever your whole foot or your whole heel or all the,
you know,
the balls of your feet are just covered in,
I mean,
I'm talking 20,
30,
40,
50 of these parasites.
They're just brutal.
So every step you see them when they're walking,
the grimacing,
when you're taking it out there screaming,
God damn Africa
[inaudible].